[Applause]
[Music]
question party is very simple you guys
in the audience are going to ask me and
tara questions and me and tarek are
going to answer your questions and it's
going to be fun like a little party
hence the name that's right so if you
have a question just raise your hand and
if we call on you stand up in your seat
and ask it ask it nice and loud so that
we can hear you but don't you pull that
mask down
this is question party not breathe on
each other party okay let's do this who
has a question you with the black mask
on your hand way up you got to be like
six feet tall as long as your arm is
nice
baby
she hit you with that exact uh-huh
girl can i do it for amber just what's
it like having transitioned from being a
writer to a host of a show what is it
like having transgender
what is it like having transitioned from
being a writer to being the host of a
show i you know what is nothing because
at late night with seth meyers the show
that's like right behind this uh well at
late night with seth meyers we wrote a
lot for ourselves
so
it was a lot of me writing for me and
then now it's also a lot of me writing
for me so the transition was really easy
the reason why we started the show was
because me and jenny were like
at the end of the week we throw in so
many sketches in the garbage we might as
well
see if they won't fast
all right so i will take the next
question uh the gentleman in the pink
shirt
what was the first thing that you uh
told your family about when you first
found out you was going to get your own
show
yeah i first told i said
gosh i don't know i clearly remember
getting late night of steph myers i was
in the parking lot of a chipotle
oh i eat is garbage
um
or i mean it's delicious healthy food
hey
i'm not gonna turn down a
um
a gift card
i was in the parking lot of a chipotle
and they called me and they told me
and and
seth well yes i mean i got the call and
uh i was like oh no seth you didn't have
to call
because i thought he was saying oh i'm
so sorry you didn't get snl
and i thought what a nice thing for him
to say
but he was he was trying to tell me oh i
have a show and i want you to write on
it which is two pieces of information i
wasn't expecting to hear so it was a bad
conversation
but i don't know what i said to mom and
dad my mom and dad like everything
they really do i mean watch i should get
out my phone and call them now and be
like a young man in a pink shirt that i
really like asked a question that would
be like i have always liked pink shirt
boy
pink shirt sweetie is my favorite
sweetie i bet you yeah that's how they
act your parents are super sweet my
parents love everything they really do
it's bad yeah and i
don't you know how like i don't tell
them about
people
because it's twofold if i tell them
about
someone who i did not like
they will hold the hate in their heart
for them until they die but if i tell
them about someone who i love they'll be
like oh you know who i love
yeah person you mentioned in passing
seven years ago
i love them they are about two parents
of four though also my mommy came to um
boom chicago 500 years ago yeah and
because tarek was the only other black
person she
held on to tarik's arm
the entire time she was there yes she
did and it was a delight and i was happy
to do it and
uh years before that when uh she was in
denver with me and jenny because
jenny was the only other minority she
held on to jenny the entire yeah
so no your mom was literally like oh you
all right and i was like i got you i got
you
she's tiny and cute
um
who else has a question you
and your suspenders you got awesome
spinners what are you wearing let me
look at it
oh oh go ahead
all right
i think i think we both know that is a
shirt i would wear yeah it
iced
is
okay i'm sorry you got your t-shirt from
arizona iced tea
from their website yeah girl don't go
shopping on iced websites for clothes
did the website go like oh so you want
more than tea
all right also like you look good but
also don't do that
simultaneously also we are all gonna now
go on iris when i speak
okay i'm sorry what is your question um
what was your favorite part about being
at the olympics
oh yeah
the best part of the olympics was
um it was it was all of it oh okay so me
and jenny
got to go to
it was beach volleyball
and um there was a heat advisory and we
did get sick but that's not what the
story is about
it was only me
jenny in a giant uh arena
where there was one million seats i'm
not good at estimating i think one
million
and literally no other human being was
seated except me and jenny mildred hegel
her name is not mildred her middle name
is not mildred i always say that i'm
sorry i do it for fun but it was like we
were like the kings of the olympics
volleyball
knew it did they bow before they would
play yeah they would bow and then go
sire
is all the time sire have for question
party this was great should we do it
again sometimes
[Applause]
you